[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARI LIBERMAN: With
me here today is
Adrian Graham, Cloud
Solutions Architect
for Media and Entertainment.
My name is Ari Liberman.
I'm a product manager
for Google Compute Engine
and for cloud GPUs.
So let's get right into it.
Thanks, Adrian.
So we have a few things
to talk about today.
This is an introductory
session, so I
want to talk about how far
we've come in the past year
since we introduced the
first generation cloud GPU.
We're going to be talking about
some exciting announcements we
have for you around virtual
workstations on GCP.
And then I'm going
to hand it over
to Adrian, who's going to
be speaking about building
a visual effects
studio in the cloud,
and show you with a demo.
So last year, around
February of 2017,
we introduced our first
generation cloud GPU, the K80.
It's an NVIDIA Tesla GPU.
We've come a long
way since then.
But I'm just going to give
you a quick refresher on why
cloud GPUs.
Computation and graphics
intensive applications
have need for massively
parallel computation.
This means that a lot of the
processing that you could
do in CPU is not enough to do
some jobs like high performance
computing and machine learning.
When you compare and
contrast a GPU to a CPU,
CPUs are great for
many jobs, for just
like your typical operations.
They can perform a lot of jobs.
But the GPU can do a lot
more parallel processing.
For example, a CPU
can have in the order
of 20 to 40 cores per CPU.
And if you have
multiple sockets,
you can scale up to
160 cores, like we
have in the recently
announced [INAUDIBLE] machine.
But on a GPU you can have
in the order of 5,000
or even more stream processors.
So you can perform a lot
of parallel computation
very quickly.
The other advantage of GPUs is
that it has much higher memory
bandwidth.
So you can be moving
data across very quickly,
compared to a CPU where
that might be slow.
And that's why in
the past few years
we've seen a significant
uptake for many applications.
And especially you've seen
today a lot of announcements
on machine learning,
where there's
been a crazy demand for
accelerators in the cloud,
for things like machine
learning training and machine
learning inference.
And then we have
also known that GPUs
are very popular
for applications
like simulation, genomics,
and, of course, visualization.
So one of our objectives
in Google Cloud Platform
is to give you one
place where you
can accelerate all
of your workloads,
regardless of what that is.
So you might have a need
for Intel Skylake CPUs.
We introduced Skylake before
any other cloud provider, back
last year.
We have a broad
range of NVIDIA GPUs.
And you saw today some more
information on cloud GPUs,
which are accelerators for
machine learning, training,
optimized for TensorFlow.
So one of the new additions
today to this family
is that we have a
graphics-optimized offering.
And I'll be talking more
about that in a second.
So why Google Cloud?
And I think you've seen
this over the years.
So we have one of the
best infrastructures.
We build fiberoptics thousands
of miles under the ocean
and over land.
And you have very
scalable performance
and reliable performance.
We've also been
working for many years
in optimizing our VMs
and our boot times.
So you can create up
to 4,000 instances
in less than a minute.
That's something you
cannot do anywhere else.
This is all with our
security built in.
So we've learned from
building services like Gmail--
you saw today [? Robert Carr ?]
talking about Gmail
and how far we've come there.
So from building services that
have over a billion users,
we take some of those lessons
and we apply them GCE.
And also you got the benefits
of per-second billing.
So you only pay for the
resources for the exact time
that you use them, not
for hours or any longer.
So how does cloud GPU work?
The way it works is when
you create an instance,
if you're familiar with
our custom machine types,
you can create a machine with
as many cores as you need,
however much memory
you need, and then
you can attach anywhere
from one up to eight GPUs.
So you have a lot
of flexibility.
And this is something that
you cannot find anywhere else.
This means that if your
application is very memory
bound, you can add more memory.
If you need a lot
more GPUs to do things
like machine learning,
you can attach them,
and you can get your
job done much faster.
But if you don't
need any of them,
you can optimize and
save a lot of money.
For example, if you're
doing a simulation that
requires very few
cores, some memory,
if we're scaling
up to 1,000 nodes,
imagine if you multiply that
times the amount of memory
for each VM.
You end up saving a lot
of money in the long run.
So we give you that
flexibility so you only
pay for what you use.
And it's by the second.
Some of the other
cloud GPU features
is that you get the GPU
in pass-through mode.
This means that you get
the bare metal performance.
We don't virtualize the device.
I talked about custom
machines, and that's
a significant benefit.
I talked about
per-second billing.
But I think, most
importantly, you get
a broad range of frameworks.
For example, within
the [INAUDIBLE]
you have [INAUDIBLE].
We have tested TensorFlow
and other frameworks.
So there's a very
broad ecosystem,
and you could take
advantage of that regardless
of your application, if
it's simulation or machine
learning or visualization.
So today we have three
families of GPUs--
the K80, the P100 that we
introduced in September
of last year, and the V100.
There's different combinations
depending on the accelerator.
For example, with the V100 you
can attach up to four GPUs.
With Volta, our
latest generation,
which was introduced
a few months ago,
you can attach up to eight.
One of the benefits of the
latest generation of the Volta
GPU is that you have NVLink,
which is a high speed
connectivity across the GPUs.
So your application could take
advantage of a bigger memory,
and much faster computation.
These are some of
the ranges also here.
You can see on how many
GPUs and how many cores,
and you have a lot
of flexibility.
You can customize your instance.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about workstations now.
And I have some
announcement for you today.
So first, if you're
in some industries,
like if you have a graphics
workstation, like media
and entertainment,
or oil and gas,
you typically could go
buy a [INAUDIBLE] card
you [INAUDIBLE] under your
desk or in some data center.
And I think that there's a lot
of advances in the recent years
that sometimes make that stale.
So you have a GPU that
might be a few years old.
It's not easy to keep up
with all the driver updates,
and to keep all the
software updates.
And also some of the
application providers
don't give consistent
support across all
the different devices.
It's getting better.
And we're hearing
from our partners
that there's more consistency,
but it's still a challenge.
One of the other problems is
that you might have silos.
You're working,
let's say, in LA,
and you're trying to connect to
somebody in Montreal or London.
And moving data is very slow.
It's difficult.
And it's also, you
don't know if there's
enough security.
So you need to make sure
that all of your data
is safe at all times.
And one of the
other challenges is
that if, for example, you're
rendering a large movie,
you want to make sure that you
have access to other services.
So when you press the button
to start doing the rendering,
that's over in close proximity.
And you can do this much faster.
So today we're going
to change this.
And we're introducing a
new type of accelerator
on Google Compute Engine.
We're introducing
the NVIDIA Tesla P4.
The P4 is a graphics
optimized GPU from NVIDIA.
But it's not only
a graphics GPU.
I'm going to talk about
some of the specs on the P4
and why it's different.
With a P4 you get 8
gigabytes of frame buffer.
So you have 8
gigabytes of memory
for your graphics
intensive application.
We have close to 200 gigabytes
per second of memory bandwidth.
But it's not only
good for graphics.
It's a card that is
great for compute.
So if you're doing things like
machine learning inference,
to give you an example, or if
you're doing video transcoding,
it's a great fit for
those use cases, too.
It also has the coding
and encoding agent.
So it's great for
reader transcoding.
With P4 we're also introducing
NVIDIA GRID support.
This means that you get
a [INAUDIBLE] workstation
in the cloud with multiple
monitoring support, 4K
resolution, with the latest
generation of workstation
clouds GPU.
This includes support for Pascal
features and deep learning.
And this is up to 1.3x the
performance of previous
generation Tesla GPUs.
What this means in
the end is that you
can take on the biggest
challenges, things
like photorealistic
environments,
immersive applications.
And as I mentioned
before, you get
the GPU and pass-through mode,
so you get the most performance
out of your GPU.
The way you attach a virtual
workstation to an instance
is the same as
you do with a GPU.
You select the accelerator type,
in this case, the NVIDIA Tesla
P4.
And it's very simple.
You just append -vws.
That converts the Tesla P4
GPU, which is a compute card,
into a virtual workstation.
You can select anywhere
from one to four.
And in this case, I'm
creating a custom machine type
with 64 cores and 300
gigabytes of memory.
But we didn't stop there.
We're also introducing
support for P100.
So if you need more
memory or more power
for your application, let's
say you're doing simulation
with something like
Discovery Live,
you need to be able
to take advantage
of more of the simulation
capabilities of your GPU.
So you can turn a P100,
with GRID support,
into a virtual workstation
if you need that much power.
One of our customers,
Schlumberger,
has been using cloud
GPUs since last year.
And Schlumberger, they have very
demanding needs for simulation,
but also for visualization.
They've deployed
virtual workstations
in several regions, and their
oil and gas subject matter
experts can power
their Petrotechnical
Suite in the DELFI cognitive
and E&P environment.
And they can power devices
all over the globe.
They take advantage of
our low-latency network
and also our global
availability of GPUs
to allow their users to make
more informed decisions,
from oil and gas exploration,
all the way to production.
So it's been very good for
them since we introduced
this in alpha a few months ago.
Here's a pricing on P4.
The P4 GPU starts at
$0.60 an hour per GPU.
You can attach one,
two, or four GPUs.
And it's the same memory
and core configurations
as a P100 GPU.
But there's one addition--
you need a license.
So there's $0.20 an hour
per license per hour.
If you need more power,
as I mentioned earlier,
you can also use a P100 GPU.
And the P100 GPU
starts a $1.46 an hour.
And you can also add
the [INAUDIBLE] license
to that to come up
with a total cost.
P4 GPUs and P100 GPUs also
are supported and preemptible,
so they're allowed for
less than 24 hours.
And they can be
preempted at any time.
So this is also supported
with a P4 and P100.
One of our partners
and customers,
BeBop Technology, they've been
using a variety of our NVIDIA
GPUs for virtual workstations.
And they've had great success
with media and entertainment
customers.
And P4 is going to be rolling
out over the next few weeks.
We're going to have them
available in locations
like Iowa, in northern
Virginia, and Netherlands.
And I think for our media
and entertainment customers,
they're going to be available
in LA as well as Montreal
over the coming weeks.
We have more regions
launching sometime
in Q4 in the end of this year.
So stay tuned,
since they're going
to be rolling out throughout
this year in more locations.
But your application
and your GPU, it's
not only about the
hardware that you have.
You also need a great client to
be able to experience the best
graphics application.
So we've partnered with Teradici
to provide Cloud Access Plus
Software through the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
You can go in,
create an instance,
and then use the fairly
cheap PC over IP protocol.
This means that you
get color accurate
and lossless video quality.
So I think it's a
great addition that
will make a lot of our
customers very successful.
The CEO of Teradici, they've
been testing on P4 and P100
and enabling some
of their customers.
And basically, they've
seen a lot of success
and a lot of great
feedback so far.
So with that, I'm
going to hand it over
to Adrian, who's
going to be talking
about how to build a virtual
effects studio in the cloud.
And thank you.
ADRIAN GRAHAM: All right.
Thank you, Ari.
So a little introduction.
I'm a cloud solutions architect
for media and entertainment,
working in Los Angeles.
And I spent, prior
to working at Google,
20 years working
in visual effects.
Worked at some big facilities.
Worked on big films.
And I mostly worked on the tech
side and the pipeline side.
So basically, it was my job
to make things work for all
the artists.
So my job now at
Google is to figure out
how to run all those same
workloads, but on the cloud.
So we've been doing a lot
of really interesting stuff.
And I'm going to sort of
go into a little more tech
detail, some of the
stuff that Ari mentioned.
First, let's have
a little primer
as to what an architecture
might look like to deploy
a virtual workstation.
So we're going to start on
the screen left-hand side.
You've got your laptops, or
what's called a zero client,
which is a thin client.
And you've got a gateway,
an internet gateway.
And you need to
connect to the cloud.
Well, you can connect
over public internet.
That's fine.
Depending on the protocol
you use to connect,
it's encrypted or not
encrypted-- hopefully
encrypted.
There's also connectivity
Cloud Interconnect products
that we offer, like Cloud
VPN, or Dedicated Interconnect
which is a 10 gigabit line.
And you can have
up to eight of them
right into a Google data center.
And that reduces latency and
ping times, the number of hops,
et cetera, et cetera.
It's based on where you
are located in the world.
But what we're doing is
we're connecting directly
to a virtual workstation.
This is the simplest
case, where we just
have an IP address
of a virtual machine,
and you just plug right into it.
And I'm going to show
you that in a second.
However, if you have more
than one virtual workstation,
you can't just click a button
and deploy, deploy, deploy.
What if have you have
100 artists all working?
You're going to
need a connection
broker or a management layer
or an orchestration layer.
And that's what Ari was talking
about BeBop Technologies
offers.
And there's other partners
that offer that as well
on Google Cloud Platform.
So then we start to build
out our infrastructure.
And this is the license server,
or the NVIDIA GRID license
that Ari was talking about.
It is completely transparent
to the user, by the way.
Once you configure a
virtual workstation
with a certain type
of accelerator,
it automatically talks to
the GRID license server,
draws a license, so
you don't have to worry
about hooking up to it.
This license server,
however, is what I'm using--
it's just a small VM, a
cloud license server--
I'm using to provide licenses
for my third party software.
I'm using Maya and
Houdini, for example.
I'll show you that in a second.
And then there's some other
data storage platforms
that you might need
some shared file system,
or if you want to
use Cloud Storage.
Those are all connected to
your virtual workstation, which
is a virtual machine
running on GCP,
just like any virtual
machine that you have.
And then we can expand out.
And this is getting
a little bit more
into the visual effects era.
And that's-- we've
got render workers,
which perform offline
compute that feed data back
to our virtual workstations.
And then we can orchestrate
it all with a Queue Manager
to distribute tasks
and everything.
So this might seem
slightly familiar to you
if you're not in visual
effects or animation
or in the
entertainment industry,
but really they're all
the same components.
You have a bunch
of compute that you
need to send out to
different workers
and orchestrate it, get it back,
record it in database entries.
But the big difference
here is that we're
able to visualize it.
So I'm going to take you
through a quick pretend day
in the life of an artist.
And there's a few people
in the audience that
know what this is all about.
Let's pretend that at 10:00
AM an artist rolls in,
and they're reviewing their
shots or their feedback
from the night before.
So they only need a
modest workstation.
They don't need a
massive workstation.
So they can spin up a
machine with only eight CPUs
and 8 gigs of RAM and
a P4, for example.
That's a relatively
inexpensive workstation.
And it's of decent power.
But once they get
feedback and they
need to start really
doing some work,
like doing some fluid
simulations or crazy amounts
of compute, they can reconfigure
their virtual workstation,
add more CPUs, add more RAM, and
add more GPUs, multiple GPUs.
And this is one of
the key elements
of GCP, is that you can
attach GPUs to almost
any configuration of a machine.
You dial up or down how
much RAM, how many CPUs.
Then you could also
add multiple GPUs.
Depending on the
type of GPU, you
can add one, two, or four
P4s or P100s, for example.
Or if you're using
V100s, you can
have up to eight V100s, which
is mind-blowingly powerful.
OK, so this artist is
done with that task.
But now they need to render it,
so they need even more power.
But they don't need
massive amounts of CPUs,
they need massive
amounts of GPUs.
So say, for example,
they're doing GPU rendering.
Well, they could
attach a bunch of GPUs
to their local
workstation, or they
can deploy a cluster of
machines with GPUs attached
and address those
in a certain way.
I'm actually going to
show you how to do that.
And this is the
game changer here,
that now you've got
your own personal GPU
farm, like your own cluster
that you could size up or down
and use as much or as little
resources as you need.
And because these
machines are all
in the same region
and zone, they
can talk to each
other really fast.
I'll get into some
of that in a bit.
All right, so let's pretend
that the artist is done at 6:00
PM, which never happens.
They stop their machine,
and they don't pay for it.
I hopped too fast there.
They don't pay for it.
So these are all
rough calculations
of what it would cost to run
any one of these configurations
on a per-hour basis,
billed by the second.
But at night when they go
home, they're not using it,
so they're not paying for it.
And also you're not paying for
a substantially powerful system
when you're only doing, like,
email and viewing movie files
and getting feedback from the
director the night before.
So that's the power of cloud.
That's really unique in that
you can deploy these resources
as you need them and size
them exactly as you need them.
So now let's move on.
That was an individual
workstation setup.
Now let's consider what it takes
to deploy an entire studio.
And when I say
studio, it doesn't
have to be a creative
content studio.
This could be just
any group of users
that wants to access a bunch
of virtual workstations.
So the three major
things we need
to talk about, latency,
bandwidth, egress.
Latency is simply
how long it takes
signal to go from
your entry point,
whether it's a laptop like I'm
using now or a zero client,
to the GPU or to the machine,
and back, round trip time.
The example I give
here is how long
it takes to go to our
Oregon data center.
And it's about 31
milliseconds roundtrip.
And of course, it depends
on your connectivity.
That's actually from the wired
connection of my laptop here.
If you do it over Wi-Fi,
it's going to be slower.
If you do it with a
dedicated interconnect
and you're in San Francisco,
it's going to be faster.
And Ari was mentioning
we've deployed GPUs--
we're going to be deploying
GPUs in some of our metro data
centers.
So Los Angeles is
coming online soon,
Montreal, London, and Sydney.
Those are all centers
for media centers.
And when you are two
milliseconds away from a data
center, you've got really
unique capabilities
that allow you to work as if
the machine was under your desk.
Bandwidth is a really
interesting problem.
And it all depends on
what's on your screen.
So if you have a
protocol like Teradici,
Teradici only sends
the delta, the changing
pixels every refresh,
every 60 hertz.
So that means that if most
of your monitor is static--
this is just an animated
GIF of me screen capturing
moving around in a Maya scene--
the stuff that's not changing,
that doesn't get resent.
So only the stuff inside that
viewport is getting resent.
So in an instance like this,
5 megabits connection is fine.
But if you're viewing
maybe a full screen video,
then your bandwidth
requirements are going to go up.
So maybe 15 megabits,
20 megabits per second.
But what if you put something
like noise on your screen,
where every single pixel is
changing with every refresh?
You could cap it at 50,
but it's going to use more.
And you know what's
hilarious, is
that the resolution of your
monitor makes a difference.
How many monitors
makes a difference.
What kind of a user you are--
if you're like a twitchy
artist, and you're constantly
moving windows around and
tumbling around the scene
and everything, you're
going to use more bandwidth.
And there are ways of
capping this per user.
So you don't have to
worry that they're
going to saturate
like a 10 gig line,
like one user's
going to saturate it.
So there are controls
and ways to restrict
how much each user is assigned.
But the way that we figure
it is that if you have
an artist with dual
2K monitors, and they
are an average workflow, you
can assign each artist 40,
45 megabits per second
and they'll be fine.
So that means that you could fit
50 artists on a single 10 gig
line, which is not--
that's not out of reach
of most facilities.
The last piece of
the puzzle is egress.
So this is something that
everybody that deals with Cloud
knows.
The data that you
pull out of Cloud
is going to cost you money.
Egress is a lot lower
with a virtual workstation
than you may think.
It's kind of hard to quantify
exactly what a pixel costs you.
Because a pixel is not
necessarily changing--
it's not either on or off.
The bit depth that it
is and how it's deployed
and the protocol that you send
it along makes a difference.
So I keep talking about
Teradici only sending the delta.
Well, that means
that you're going
to pay less for data that's sent
down that's not moving as much.
If an artist keeps a video
looping on their screen
overnight, you're
going to pay for that.
So you need to have
these controls in place
to make sure that idle
resources, resources
that aren't being
attended to, are not
utilizing excess bandwidth.
This is an actual
chart of, I think,
three months of my egress usage.
And I've been demoing
this stuff all the time.
And it comes to
a total of $3.79.
It's a lot lower
than you might think.
But there are computations
and calculations
that you can use to
do rough estimates.
So one final thing before
we get into the demo,
and that's you really
need a dedicated line.
If you really want to
have a cloud studio,
you need to have an isolated
line that is designated just
for transmission to and from
your virtual workstations.
We've had some people
run proof of concepts,
and they complain
to us that, oh,
it started getting really slow.
I don't know what's going on.
And we have a 50 gig
or 100 gig connection.
Well, it turns out that
they had some massive Aspera
upload going that was totally
stepping on and crushing
their bandwidth.
So this just goes
to show, you need
to have dedicated bandwidth and
an assigned allotment per user
on there.
All right.
So the demo that I'm going
to show you basically
takes you down the path
of three steps, sort
of a three-step journey.
The first journey is
talking about what's
only possible on
cloud in general.
And the second
step is only what's
possible on Google Cloud.
And the third is only what's
possible on Google Cloud
with virtual workstations.
So I am on a laptop here.
And I just switched to
the Teradici client, which
is a software client,
runs on your laptop,
runs on Windows, Mac.
And there's also a hardware
client, which is a little box.
But what you're seeing
here, this is not--
there we are.
So this isn't very
interesting, right?
This is a 160 core,
160 vCPU machine
running in Oregon that is
running six concurrent fluid
simulations, using a
program called Houdini.
I'll get into that in a second.
But what this is doing is
this is generating literally
terabytes of data every hour.
And it's writing all that
data to a Cloud Filestore, 64
terabyte, premium instance.
Cloud Filestore--
I don't think it
was announced at the keynote,
but it's our managed shared NFS
file system now.
So up to 64 terabytes.
And it is manageable as an NFS
filer on Windows and Linux.
But the amazing part here
is that, so this data
is being written from
this one massive machine.
So what can I do
with all this data?
Well, I can visualize it
on a virtual workstation.
So first I'm going to
show you this data is--
when you do a screen
capture of it,
it looks something like this.
I'm running six
of these right now
on that virtual workstation.
This is pre-rendered.
This is not running
live, that you see.
But I wanted to give you an
idea of why this is useful.
These are what we call wedges.
When you do a simulation for--
it doesn't have to
be a simulation.
It could also be an
animation or any type of--
seem to be getting a little
bit of-- there we are.
It's really hard to tweak
all the parameters at once.
So what they do
is they'll come up
with something that looks OK.
And then they'll
deploy six or 10 or 20
variations that have one tiny
little parameter shifted.
And then you can render out
each one, and you could view it
and you could say,
OK, well wedge one
has the parameter set at 0.5.
And wedge two has the
parameter set at 0.75,
or something like that.
And you'll be able to see,
oh my god, just changing
that one little parameter gives
me this massive difference.
This is the playback
of the movie file.
That's why it's a little choppy.
But the idea here is that I've
got that massive machine that's
able to write out all
of these simulations,
run them all at the same time.
And we're able to-- let
me just quit out of here.
And we're able to
now visualize them.
So this is a program
called Houdini.
Let me just get a little
room for my mouse here.
This data, I'm able to read
live off of that Filestore.
This is a different machine.
This is my virtual workstation.
I've been viewing all that
on my virtual workstation
that you've been looking at.
So I'm able to read
all that data live.
And we're talking
hundreds of millions
of particles, gigabytes of
data that I'm able to see--
my mouse keeps sliding down.
I'm just going to put
this guy down there.
I'm able to visualize this
stuff and read it right off
that Cloud Filestore,
as it's being
written by that massive
simulation engine.
So this is really
important, because now I'm
generating all the
data on the cloud,
and I'm leaving it up
there on the cloud.
So I don't have to download
these terabytes of data
to my on-prem
workstation to do this.
And I can access
this from anywhere.
I'm on a laptop here.
I can take my laptop and
bring it on an airplane,
and with Wi-Fi on
an airplane I've
actually connected to
these workstations before.
It's not very-- you've
got 1 megabit per second.
Teradici's very adaptive
to different bit rates.
All right, so we've got this
simulation that we've chosen.
And we like it.
So now what can we
do with it next?
I'm going to move over to an
application called Maya now.
And again, this is all
running on the same machine.
This is a standard Linux virtual
workstation running in Oregon,
running CentOS 7.
We can do Windows and Linux.
So this is an
application called Maya.
And this is a meshed
version of that simulation.
Actually, let me
show you what that
looks like with this turned on.
There we are.
So once the simulation is
done with the particle-based
simulation, you can put it
through a process by which you
actually surface it.
You mesh it.
And this is the resulting mesh.
But this mesh is in a file
format called Alembic.
And these files are massive.
This is, I think,
a 6 gigabyte file.
And I can scrub through it.
This is, again, all stored
on the Cloud Filestore
that I was talking
about earlier.
So I'm able to scrub around, and
now I can actually go and turn
on rendering.
So once we have the scene
simulated and meshed,
now we want to
look at how to make
it appear as if it's water, a
character coming out of water.
And there's a lot more
that I could talk about,
but I'm running out of time.
But if you want
to see more, we're
doing this in a cloud studio
across the street and upstairs.
I'll talk about
that in a second.
So I'm going to go into--
we're using a
renderer called V-Ray.
And V-Ray is by a company
called Chaos Group.
And V-Ray takes
advantage of GPUs.
It has the ability to
render on CPUs or GPUs.
But because GPUs can
run parallel processes
of a way, way higher
core count, they
can render a lot
faster than on CPUs.
So here I've got--
on this workstation
it's a single P100.
And I'm able to tumble around
and look at this scene.
And I can change the
lighting if I want.
I can go and increase the--
where did that setting go--
the intensity [INAUDIBLE]..
So I can tweak my scene and
make my shaders look the way
that I need them to,
and make the surfaces
look the way I need them to.
But you'll see this is
a progressive renderer.
So as I tumble around in
real time, it'll update.
And it'll sort of
iteratively update
until it achieves a certain
what we call shading rate.
So that's great.
This is fast.
But it could be even faster.
And I'm limited to the number
of GPUs I have on this machine.
But this is the cloud.
So I'm going to deploy an entire
cluster of GPUs to render this.
This cluster will be external
to this virtual workstation.
They will be-- remember
that diagram earlier
where I showed the
virtual workstation,
and then below it was a
whole cluster of GPUs?
Well, I'm going to
turn that on now.
So I'm going to turn
off rendering for now.
I'm going to go
into the Option box.
And I will turn on--
let me just quit out of--
I'm going to go to
the Settings tab.
And I'm going to turn on
distributed rendering.
I seem to be a little bit--
think my connectivity
is-- there we go.
OK.
Ah, all right.
I'm going to turn on Use
Distributed Rendering.
So I have a bunch
of virtual machines
that are running V-Ray
in sort of server mode.
And they're all located at
these internal IP addresses.
So these virtual machines
are in the same project
as my virtual workstation.
And you address them
over a particular port.
It's a feature of V-Ray.
So now I'm going to
turn on rendering again.
And if I look at the shell
that I launched Maya in,
you could see, it's
starting the V-Ray server
on all of those machines
at a particular frame.
So if we give it a second or
two, we let them all catch up.
So now when I tumble, it's
able to resolve way faster.
You can actually see Teradici
adapting to the changing bit
rate.
Because I think my connection
speed dropped for a second
there.
But it adapted,
and now it's back.
So it's resolving a lot faster.
And this is something
that's really
only possible on Google Cloud.
Because the speed with
which my virtual workstation
is talking to these
render servers
is 32 gigabits per second.
That's actually a
newly announced--
we announced that a couple of
weeks ago at a launch event.
It used to be 16
gigabits per second.
But now these machines are able
to communicate with each other
at 32 gigabits per second.
So the last thing I wanted to
talk about is our cloud studio.
So if you go across the
street to Moscone West
and go upstairs, we
are running a live--
and this is not a demo--
we're running a live
virtual cloud studio
with five artists working
on virtual workstations.
Four of them are here.
One of them is in Los Angeles.
And they're all working
on a similar set-up
that you saw here.
They're using
virtual workstations,
writing to Cloud Filestore,
running using BeBop,
orchestrating with
BeBop, using NVIDIA GPUs,
viewing it with Teradici, and
a whole other bunch of partner
technologies and
internal technology.
So I urge everybody, if
you have more questions,
go across the street,
come talk to us.
We're there throughout
the show, because we
are building a 30-second
commercial for GCP
during the show.
So you'll see the animators
actually working and running
things like Maya and
rendering with V-Ray
and rendering using Zinc.
I could talk to you
about that there.
They will be delivering
a finished piece
by Thursday afternoon, which
will go live on our website.
[MUSIC PLAYING]